- What am I gonna make?
(burp)
Got no idea.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Kayla, I'm a
lifestyle writer at BuzzFeed
and I tried to be a cook today.
I have some food experience,
I know how to make general stuff.
I think I can get away with making
food that tastes and looks good.
My name is Vaughn,
I am a Tasty producer.
I grew up working in a barbecue restaurant
in North Carolina.
I have lived in France
and I've lived in Thailand.
I've got kind of a slight
background in pastry.
I didn't really know Kayla
before this all started
but when I met her,
I was like, wow,
who is this beautiful angel that
I have to go against
and hopefully crush her soul.
I'm nervous, I'm but I'm ready.
- Let's do it.
(techno music)
- Preferable that we have more money.
- Like 50.
- Can we bargain?
- No, he said no.
(techno music)
I don't know anything
about being hung over
so this is gonna be tough.
- Are you kidding?
- Okay, yeah.
- I saw your Instagram
story from last week.
- I'm a liar.
Well when I heard that the challenge
was hangover food
I was like, yes,
because at first off,
it's has to be like greasy
and probably not healthy for you.
At least it wasn't something like
make a nice dinner for someone.
I'd be like, ohrr.
- I think it can happen.
- I'm confident that I have some skills
in hangover food that I have the potential
to kick your ass.
- Okay, well I mean
I've been around that block a couple times
so you aint no hollow bad girl.
(laughing)
- Wow, it looks like there's a lot
of good stuff in here.
I feel a little better now.
- Let's do this.
- Alright.
Are we ready?
- Alright, bring it on.
I'm gonna go in!
(upbeat music)
Pasta, I don't wanna make pasta.
So I walk in and the first thing I see
is the bread,
it's like right in the front of the store
and I'm like, yes,
because in the back of my mind I said,
if they have stuff for
grilled cheese that's
the perfect hangover food.
Vegan, oh my God, perfect,
like greasy, bacon, some
tomatoes in there would be good.
I was thinkin about all the things
that like I could have been missing
for something as simple
as a grilled cheese
and I was like (ding) ding butter.
Key to a delicious grilled cheese.
I knew I was under budget
so I had a little bit
of extra money to spend
and I was like what else would someone
have when they're hung over.
Hair of the dog get some beer.
I don't know if a grilled cheese
is like enough to win
but it is an easy food
that people would make
if they were hung over.
I like dump everything on the counter
and the guy rings it
up and it's 25 dollars.
Perfect, I'm under budget five dollars.
I'm gonna take that five dollars
and celebrate later when I win.
- Go get 'em tiger!
- Thanks.
(upbeat music)
- 10 minutes starting.
I was thinking fried food, greasy food.
When I'm hungover I want a meal.
I don't want just like
dainty finger sandwiches.
I initially grabbed bacon
because bacon is amazing
on anything.
I could literally shit on a stick
and cover it with bacon
and the crowds gonna go wild.
I'm gonna get some eggs.
Ah man.
I stumble across chow mien noodles.
I find water chestnuts.
I find baby corn.
I find Hoisin sauce.
I find chili sauce.
I find ground garlic.
You need something spicy.
You need something flavorful
to kind of get your immune system
back in order.
Time is ticking down.
- 25.
I've got five dollars left.
So I've got to go get a beer.
We're gettin' some booze y'all.
- 29.
(gasp)
- 29 dolla's.
(upbeat music)
I'm getting all my stuff prepped
and the only thing running through my mind
is like, how am I going
to make this food within
30 minutes.
I'm ready, you're goin' down, yo.
- See you on the other side.
- Are we dying?
(laughing)
- You are once you try my food.
It's amazing.
- From food poisoning.
- Thokay.
- Hey, I need some help.
(laughing)
- Like we literally just started.
- I don't know how to turn this thing on.
Literally they're like go
and Vaughn's like ho,
zoo, zoo, zoo, do, do,
and I was like, what am,
I don't know how to turn this thing on.
- As we say in the South,
bless your heart.
Well the on button might
be your first hint.
- I think it was pretty
obvious that I was making
a grilled cheese.
I had very basic ingredients
and I look over
and Vaughn has this like selection
of condiments, and like noodles,
and oranges and I'm like,
what the hell is he making?
Like what in the world could
he be making with that?
What are you making over there?
- Wouldn't you like to know!
- Oh, I'm Vaughn, I'm mmmm.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, hear that sizzle?
Amazing.
Ahhh!
- Do you need some help over there?
- [Kayla] Yep.
- Alright, come on.
- Show me how to get this bacon
to not stick.
- It sticks at first
because it's like developing
all that fat content
and then it's going to naturally
release from the pan.
(upbeat music)
- I can't hear you over here
over the smell of my delicious bacon.
- [Vaughn] You're deliciously raw bacon.
- [Kayla] True.
- True, your sposed to
trash talk right back girl.
We were tryin' to trash talk each other
and she just kept being like
oh, but I know you're gonna do great.
I'm like, girl, this is a competition.
- We're like smack talking each other.
It gets easier.
(laughing)
It gets easier to talk shit about him.
- I takin' a trip to flavor town.
- He's over here like,
throwin' salt in his like dish
and squeezing oranges
and I'm like, what is this?
Like I'm over here like
butter, bread, toast.
- Gonna give 'em somethin'
that they won't forget.
Just like mom used to make.
- I don't think Vaughn
knew what he was making.
He just put a bunch of ingredients
in a pot and it looked good.
Ooh, you're gonna do that?
You shouldn't do that.
(laughing)
I'm so.
- Shouldn't do what?
- Whatever you just put in there,
are you sure you want to do that?
- [Vaughn] Yes, I'm sure.
- [Kayla] Ooh.
- These are at like
spicy, delicious noodles.
I am literally making
what I call everything
but the kitchen sink chow mien.
It's got depth of flavor,
it's got acidity, it's got your sweetness,
it's got your saltiness, it's got texture,
it's got a fried egg, it's got bacon.
- I'm torn if I wanna make
like a stacked grilled cheese.
I don't know how that would really work.
- All competitiveness aside,
I would say a double decker grilled cheese
would be bangin'.
Go big or go home.
Again, this is a competition.
If that's what helps her win,
then I kind of does a win for myself.
- I mean, come on.
If you were hung over,
wouldn't you want to eat that?
Ta-da!
(upbeat music)
- Oh, mamma!
A double decker grilled cheese
is wild in all of the best ways.
- Thank you.
- I'm very impressed with you.
- I'm glad I took the risk
and I would like to say
that sunny side up egg
on top is like,
perfection.
- Thank you.
I looked at it earlier
and I almost wish I could do that myself.
Friendship grew out of this.
- Out of darkness.
Let's get people to eat it.
- Alright and.
- So they can tell me that I'm gonna win.
- And that I'm better.
- You need something quick, easy, simple
and tasty when you're hung over
so, sandwich for me.
(beep)
- This was definitely a good attempt
and there's a lot of bread in there
to soak it up
but if I want carbs,
I'm goin' for pasta.
(beep)
- When you're hung over you don't,
you're not excited about dining.
You're trying to find anything
that will make you not feel bad.
I'd definitely go grilled cheese.
(beep)
- This spicy Thai thing
is pretty good.
I'm gonna go with that one.
(beep)
My favorite.
- So you got two drastically
different executions.
This one is everything
and tastes like nothing.
This is simple
and tastes the best I think.
I would say my winner
is definitely got to be
the grilled cheese.
(beep)
(laughing)
Hair of the dog.
Oh my gosh.
(laughing)
(zap)
Wait, do I have
to like retaste everything now
with the beer?
- I'm scared.
- Dddddddddddd, ahhh.
- Me?
- No!
Probably more appropriate
hangover food than
- I liked.
- Chow mien.
- I liked the creative direction you
were going in.
- Thank you, thank you
- People just picked mine
because they're like bah, cheese
and bread!
- But it was deliciously executed
- Thank you.
- Cheese and bread.
- I'm actually really proud
of myself.
Was really nervous you know,
going up against someone
who works at Tasty.
Hello, that's a big deal,
so he wouldn't be there
unless he was really talented
and he is.
- I know who I'm catering
my cuisine to now.
The audience of a
less sophisticated palate.
Let's just say.
(laughing)
- Load a slight jab in.
- A low blow.
- I'm sorry I can't see
- A little defensive there.
You from the shine on my trophy.
(laughing)
- Alright, I'm done, I'm done.